it is a nervous drive through unfamiliar
territory this neighborhood now under
the control of Iraqi forces was home to
many Isis fighters the SWAT team is on
the hunt for an is explosives expert
called Ali Qatar at a house where he's
staying
the suspect is dragged onto the streets
warning shots are fired as his
interrogators humiliated in front of his
sister and wife he insists they've got
the wrong man what's happened here shows
how difficult it is for the Iraqi
security forces to capture Islamic state
fighters we've gone underground and are
now blending in with the civilian
population the man that they thought was
- turns out to be an entirely different
person it appears that they were given
the wrong information by their Informer
so many men have been rounded up the
security forces are finding it hard to
process them in the back of a truck
those accused of terror a terror fight
the courtyard of the mosque nearby is
soon full of local men they've been
ordered here by an intelligence unit
from Baghdad
names are called out IDs are checked and
wrists are stamped
Oh Muhammad Ali and the swats
headquarters they have a long list of
wanted men this is his picture we sent
this to the intelligent these documents
that Islamic state have left behind very
important document and this will help
you catch them yes there is an urgency
to this anti-terror operation in the
past few months have been several
suicide bomb attacks in eastern Mosul
the Iraqi army is now guarding the
streets but people are not reassured we
scare from this this people people are
still scared here yeah you see they said
maybe they come back here again you see
yeah they have had many many many people
they have sleeper cells yeah the
soldiers try to be friendly but they are
strangers in much of Mosul the children
are scared as a gunshot rings out they
sometimes rely on unlikely sources for
information
this little girl leads the way
identifying the house of a suspect the
wanted man is taken for questioning the
hunts for Isis's rank and file is a
major test for Iraq's forces providing
security without alienating the local
population will not be easy
Alex Rossi Sky News eastern Mosul